Larry P. Arnn:
The government is the necessary solution to
a problem, and that is us.
Lord knows what we might do without laws.
There's a problem with government.
That's us too.
First of all, the name means something cool.
It means to set a thing up firmly in place.
It's actually like the word for statue.
Just think of this particular problem.
If you're going to have more than one person
make the law, you're going to have to have
a constitution to describe how that's done,
or else you're going to have wars all the
time about who gets to make the law.
The problem with government, the government
is a solution to a problem.
The necessary solution to a problem, and that
is us.
There's a problem with government, that's
us too.
Madison wrote, "What is government but the
profoundest of all commentaries on human nature.
If men were angels, no government would be
needed.
If angels were to govern men, neither internal
nor external controls on the government would
be necessary."
Since it's true that both the thing that needs
protecting and the danger to it are the same
thing, then you have to have some method of
both assembling and granting power, and of
restraining power.
Our constitution is the best at that in all
of history, and the explanations of it by
the people who wrote it are the most profound
explanations of that kind in all of human
history.